what is it like being a quarantine the
corn they're calling you mama
told us yesterday we were on the phone
with her that they're calling all the
teenagers of this time quarantine all
right what's up people
my quarantine stash is coming along very
nicely only taking me about a week to
grow this much man I can't grow facial
hair to save my life but it's kind of
it's kind of a fun project that I don't
need to go see anyone even though you
guys are gonna see me it's kind of fun
to see how much of this can grow in the
time that we've been stuck at home I
stopped shaving the upper lip and the
last day we shot JK news and it's
Saturday now so it's a week and two days
since I've shaved upper lip is what I
got so far we'll see by the time what
whenever once that winds was holding in
supposedly like April 19th that's a date
you're not seeing you until then might
as well I don't know what's the ml
trimming why I'm hoping for right now is
for the top layer of hair to grow long
enough to cover the bottom layers of
hair so it looks thicker right now you
can kind of see in between you see the
pores and it's just not very thick yeah
well what are you doing I'm baking the
cake you're baking a cake I like it oh
my own all from scratch no help from
Betty mm-hmm
yeah mr. Crocker who who who's that has
been getting busy in the kitchen which
is very very rare I have to say very
very rare the other night you were where
were we making the other night and she
loved yes she was making enchiladas the
other night we have footage of that
actually
can I tell you a magnificent today is
not important no you know what I thought
you did that you've got the camera you
flipped it to like do a selfie style of
like you talking to it all what happened
hey I'm making enchiladas how's it feel
to the housewife / mom and cooking in
your own kitchen
other stuff I mean not like full-on
meals like yes chefs that only you like
I take a lot of shortcuts a lot of
things a lot of cans boxes but get the
job done but I used to cook before you
and then it's been we've been together
for eight years almost right now yeah it
was count but all these years
cooking is you're passionate so I'm like
I'm not gonna get I'm not gonna stand in
the way of your passion you can stand in
the way of my passion any day because I
am so happy to see you cooking and I
don't know it just feels nice to I don't
know have someone cook for you you know
I get
I don't know makes me warm right now
yeah it really does smell great by the
way
so I already fried all these Sofia right
Hado yeah fry it you mojado know you
dorado it you mojado it and then you
roll all of it yeah you see stuff it
Riano yes yeah okay you throw out of it
you mojado it and then you relleno it
yeah vanish on the coin please do this
again years and then it she was so cute
because at the end of it she was like
thanks for calling me like you make me
feel like a mom and I'm like I need you
you're my mom of course actually kind of
like a little baby tell ya how happy you
were to throw it I can only imagine how
happy your mom was so I just see you and
your mom connect like oh I got share a
moment
yeah I could like you know this whole
quarantine stuff she's been working from
home a lot and she was like
nice for you to need me I'm like yeah I
need you can't do this without you I
don't remember these recipes wait two
more minutes then we're done I just
forgot to make rice so we're only eating
enchiladas and I was like I think
dinner's ready
I never get to say it
[Music]
have an enchilada turned out really
really nice Hey mmm I was supposed to
send my mom a photo of it the enchiladas
and I told her it forgot because I was
just like let's just get people eating
nobody likes cold food yeah we should
probably stay in more that we have more
chances of you cooking more often yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah I could this is the
only way I can cook those it's coming
out of like packaged things like a can
or a box it's edible right it's me still
end up eating it at the end of the day
yeah I like it I don't mind if it's out
of a package and I also like the fact
that we're using up the rest of this
milk it's actually past this day but and
now we're just trying to like get rid of
it before it does get stinky and so
baking a cake is a nice excuse to use
some milk and eggs and we have a lot of
eggs to smell good mm-hmm you got really
far into the processor it's best to use
water but milk should make it creamier
right I think so
more flavor baddies flavors milk has fat
reduced fat milk Oh true its essence of
milk it's not really you know what I
mean like the Latroy water Siri has the
natural essences of Pamplemousse e
whatever that means
I mean it's grapefruit it's another word
for great I don't even know how to
pronounce that pamplemoose Pamplemousse
pomplamoose pamplemoose's are real eggs
we will not be using essence of eggs oh
I can already see the strawberry now
that is essence of strawberry no real
strawberries in there yeah however we do
have real strawberries here which then
will counter the essence of strawberries
there so in fact we are making a real
strawberry cake see
[Music]
it's so satisfying to watch an egg drop
egg drop soup mm-hmm open-hand yes
noise the New York morning our trashcan
hasn't been very responsive to the whole
open can thing you really have to we
don't need it to open but every time we
needed to open minimum we have to ask it
twice every time I'm like are you crazy
or something you're gonna tell you're
making toys you don't have to tell me
everything toy more like three or four
times it's pretty bad pretty bad but I
learned they'll eventually nasty ones
the last thing told me about the toilet
seat cover mm-hmm
yeah many more time since lice have a
lot of ones you can make orange blossom
cake too
I use the whisk or should I use both of
those I might get scared doing this
thing it's gonna fling it all around
their kitchen yeah we sure got the one
that's enclosed
[Music]
look at that nice like the tip I'm doing
a Pam look oh yeah you know it's funny
we keep saying where we gonna cake but
in reality we're making cupcakes
oh yeah cupcakes yeah yeah oh yeah
cupcakes BAM kind of a happy that we're
making cakes though because we've been
really bored been really bored and we're
running out of things to do that doesn't
seem repetitive wake up play some video
games watch them office yeah
eat some food wash dishes clean up
around here yeah every day is kind of
like the same so baking a cake
one feels festive because cake is always
festive mm-hmm and two it's we haven't
done it yet
yeah ever we've never baked a change
together before you and me haven't
Johnny so well I mean you're standing
here so now we have
as I go I don't know like I'm never in
the kitchen but whenever I am like if
I'm done using something I like to it
just wash and put it away with a quick
and then resume true you know what this
is dumb I have a measuring cup that I
could just pour it out of can you tell I
never do things around here you know
your baking stuff though I know you know
a lot more about baking than I do
because I know a very I know zero that's
not true you know how to make done touch
true but it's not baking though and
there was a day where I was like I'm
interested in learning how to bake bread
I tried it and I ended up getting cooked
dough and I was like rock hard it was
heavy it wasn't fluffy at all I missed
something like the Easterner work the
way I had intended it to or something
but yeah and then when I was reading
blogs about learning how to make bread
and stuff people a lot of bakers out
there bloggers fakeblock baking bloggers
made it a point say baking bread is true
but baking in not cakes and and and
pastries and stuff like if it doesn't
actually use the yeast so you don't need
to make anything rise there's no science
to it so they're like that is child's
play baking bread and anything that
needs to like we call it rise yeah don't
make the dough making dough rise is real
baking so yeah I guess we're not really
baking today then what that said yeah
you know what you know all the purists
and you know that's that's like foo-foo
talk this is we're baking for the family
who cares you get to enjoy some
strawberry cupcake exactly that
strawberry ice cream - oh my goodness
strawberry icing for strawberry cupcakes
served a la mode topped with fresh
strawberries now that sounds pretty good
strawberry doubt
mmm fantastic
so since the last time you've logged we
took a couple days off and blogging we
got this guy we put up a fantastic
looking golden mail holder it's a nice
contrasting color to the turquoise teal
colors that we have on the backsplash
now get that beautiful beautiful
beautiful Wow
we have a dustpan slash broom stick
holder and we put this up recently so
that we don't need to put this stuff
like down there somewhere and it's all
hard to get tips really good at knowing
that things need to have a special place
and it will help you stay maintain order
around the house
[Music]
so I don't know how I'm supposed to do
this but I've seen people on Instagram
because I really love watching cake
decorating videos and I see them like
microwave the frosting and then it gets
all melty and stuff and then they like
dip the cupcake in it but these cupcake
liners they have like paper inside so
it's like aluminum and then there's
paper inside and then so like the
cupcake completely slipped out of my
hand when I was trying to dip it so
instead I'm doing it this way which is
like the messiest way possible probably
but my mouth is so watery it smells so
good do you want to decorate it
sure trying to see if I wanted to but
that boys just all about the office
these days he's flexing his his
independence yep did you want to help me
that great speak of the devil oh yeah oh
we can't I mean I don't even know how
else to do it other than this but can't
open see see it doesn t was in the Isaac
either open open cane cane it's so funny
the most disobedient trash can ever
smell be yeah here I'm just like trying
to hold it and then go to zoom there I
grab some and then like by dripping it
and then I play dress
[Music]
all right so we're eating extra frosting
for that monster we're eating our icing
guys they're the same thing frosting
icing is that different things I think
so frosting is the the fluffy one right
it gets hard like that right no idea
frostings on the birthday cakes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I mean heck to cupcake black leather
generally enjoy decorating tuvok tedious
no he did a lot but I think he got too
dirty I was thinking now that I'm done
but uh didn't say open can you know I
was thinking I should have been putting
this frosting in a bag like the ziplock
bag or something and I could have
squeezed it all out that might have been
simpler but it's already the end I'm
already done you did a great job
decorating baby yeah that's deep you
didn't like it okay yeah what is your
thing these days no no do you have a
thing yeah the office do my school work
yeah finish it in the morning I know
you're so responsible dude
by the time I'm waking up cuz like I go
to sleep later than Isaac and then he'll
wake up before me and then my time I
wake up he's already done his homework
or like halfway done I'm like wow that's
cool you're so responsible I have to
tell you anything
nice yeah it's nowhere life has been so
far I wouldn't have this experience
mommy doesn't have this experience but
what is it like being a quarantine
quarantine told us yesterday we were on
the phone with her that they're calling
all the teenagers of this time
quarantine and then also the coronal
anneals
I forgot the other ones my favorite was
they're calling it the Boomer remover
remover Oh baby's been born now or
something like that oh my that's dark
wait all the babies being born yeah back
after World War two a lot of babies were
born and they called it the baby boom
because like once everyone came back
from war they started pumping out kids
but then now because of this coded 19 a
lot of the people are that are dying are
like the older people like the elderly
and Oh calling it boomer remover because
all the baby boomers are now elderly and
are calm pretty dark but yeah so how is
it like being a teen in such a time and
going to school and staying on top of
things and being responsible with life
still but the best yes yeah I get on a
bed bed do homework and then I can say
up for as long as I want sleep in for as
long as I want and do homework until
when every time I want whenever I want
when I want
do you feel like you're being more
responsible because the time is in your
hands and not necessarily having to
follow this guide or do you feel like
you're being less responsible like I'm
being more responsible I think so too
actually
you're born to be an entrepreneur huh
you start your own business call your
own shots make your own hours and be
accountable all by yourself yeah yeah
you're not gonna work for a big
corporation maybe maybe never no never
no and in the future you're far enough
to never see them ever true I like this
cupcake so they're coming on nicely it's
gonna be rich
[Music]
if you want it to be here and the
grapevine that you're pretty responsible
to stay so you can call this lunch I'll
let you decide it's a traffic yes look
right oh you want to look roaring yeah
go for it
[Music]
very very responsible oh you did a great
job by the cupcakes
you look fantastic I had help from my
work mm-hmm
help that great crew I have to say I
think this one's my favorite design yeah
that was actually the first cupcakes
that I started with where I was like
maybe you might do little slices and I
can like make them stand up but they
weren't they weren't sticking the
frostings I guess the frosting might
have parted by then yeah and then I was
like how does lay them flat and that's
where the residents cut true the og is
the best always original Isaac were you
looking for a pizza
[Laughter]
are you hungry I ate not too long ago
personally but if you like pizza the
pizza is in here
why we're looking for pizza in the boxes
then if you saw these in the fridge for
some pizzas in there oh well well
they're in this bag now makes you think
Oh cause you can see through the bag
you're like I know what's in there
not intriguing we ordered pizza
yesterday because Casey was craving some
yeah and I try to stay away from Pizza
Pizza really activates my eczema I think
it's the cheese but like sometimes
you're just like you just gotta eat some
pizza I don't know this quarantine like
every morning I'm waking up and I'm like
oh yeah this is my life right now I have
I just have to stay at home and just be
at home cuz there's no taking news for
the next two weeks true I'm like that's
all feels like this dream is lasting too
long you want it to end down like am I
gonna wake up yet uh-huh
some days I wake up and I'm like what's
the point we're stuck in the matrix
there's a glitch and won't let us out
either
you gotta overpower the systems like oh
yeah
what zero
she says that can't remember me me me me
and then that's how she discovered that
oh right quite a time we start watching
that show too because now we're in some
form of like you know and I'm just like
mmm so relatable guys and then like the
fact that we can't do anything without
technology
oh yeah that's in that part that part
very very very relatable yeah I want one
he's he served mine eylem mode yes whoo
what is this one cherry vanilla
I've never even I didn't know that with
you man a flavor you nice oh you are
generous with the ice cream I'm trying
to make it like a nice round scoop on so
we don't have like the traditional ones
all right
oh we should get those little the
release signature you know those are
cool and all but cuz I had one growing
up and those are really hard to clean
and like it gets rusted oh yeah no thank
you
yeah that's this one but those aren't
good for like a perfect sphere true you
can do it too with this one that's some
kind of like trying to shape it come on
coffee to go with this strawberry coffee
what you want more there's like nothing
your skin does not do you well it's a
very true ice cream is one of those
things you just can't live without
for our afternoon delight you have a
strawberry delight delight quarantine
delight for the afternoon delight a
strawberry delight
Jovie according to let you know like
Turkish delight yeah oh how we put so
much work into the cupcake and the first
thing we're gonna do and cheers with
pizza it's true mmmmmm ice cream never
fails
okay I see tests I tested him in the Eee
pass solicit film I know you should just
dip the whole thing into ice cream just
smashed all the ice cream you can do
that good moist
I like moist like cupcakes there's more
to it
oh I can feel the moistness you know
it'll be really really cool since we
have so much cupcake it's a blue you
might around the neighborhood and go in
hey welcome to the neighborhood here's
some cupcakes for you except I just
realized that's the quarantine to show
this probably wouldn't want to take
cupcakes on strangers were you what are
we gonna do with all this cupcake this
it's a lot I had one and I was like I
think I'm maybe good for two more over
the next couple of days okay I don't
know if I could eat a cupcake a day you
need a cupcake a day I'm not a sweet
person I mean that's why it's feels
intense right now for me to finish all
this cupcakes but because like quite a
bit of batter in each one it only made
17 cupcakes oh that's a relief
yeah we can
well we do have the same amount they're
just condensed into ya know cakes
there's like 20 more cupcakes worth of
cupcakes true but it only added up to 17
a yielded 17 that's that that's that
Baker talk on the back of the boxes
yield 17 cupcakes that'd be good for
tomorrow's oatmeal in the morning really
it's just mashed up avocados with salt
and pepper and lemon baby food that was
really good I made a I made a taco bulb
as we had some shredded chicken and some
enchilada sauce from the enchiladas that
TIFF made and I mix that with the
chicken and put some and some rice some
lettuce and some guac it's pretty good
now that's cute hey you we woke you up
you haven't tried out your new cat tree
though and look at my tie down there
it's too lazy we have like the laziest
cats in the world yeah so lazy they
match the owners true all right
then a couple of hours since our cupcake
endeavor they're also there but now it
is dinner and we're all eating something
different Isaac chose Pizza TIFF well I
made a taco bowl out of some enchilada
and taco supplies that we had leftover
what's going on with him but his food
comes out on a time like a timer thingy
and they have to wait a few more minutes
he's not happy about it like it's so
impolite you start eating dinner without
me yeah and I'm eating some leftover
Chinese food that I made I don't know
why I keep forgetting this microwave
door but yeah I thought it was kind of
cool that we're eating our ethnic
backgrounds for dinner and then while
he's eating his uh well he is American
Oh true American it's true
yeah braised beef veggies mm-hmm back to
the beginning - Susan - now episode
eight we cycled through
that's how bored we are
[Music]